hello and welcome to this video planks
cat chick a stage last again who
recently killed me ok that's it going
for 94 maybe an interesting idea nature
for and let's try it try to be a little
bit unnerving here yeah all the way back
Bishop 86 has some annoyance value and
night to d3
yeah if it goes III bishop 86 are we not
that great but tonight to d3 isn't that
bad yeah why not check there's no reason
to take on see one already yeah c4 is an
idea now just support this
Queen 85 and tending to take on be too
yeah that looks good looks like a very
good bank oh sure don't let me see a
good move for him comes back I can just
take me to hear right McKnight take SIA
or something I'm on that square a lot 90
fun I take the rook so we'll see 3 yeah
okay I can take the exchange now but is
that the right way to do it first take
this and now have a look I can also take
a three probably that's better
he has no square for the rook anyway
some fatigue you should take this is
actually unprotected don't really see
how to benefit from that
we just go from night see for am not
ideal
so what am i doing next year maybe I
should just take the four finally I was
also thinking just see two but taking
the exchange it's not bad it's strictly
pretty good yeah I'm not not taking this
stuff
I really didn't play that well maybe is
can still play Queenie for some stuff
and then I can take you five actually
this was my goal here to simplify it a
little bit and just try to win my simple
means check check check white resigns ok
happy to have beaten a reasonably strong
player him but recently won against me
pretty convincingly yeah the opening
result he was very good out of the bank
oh um yeah this is a new trend to not
immediately take on a six and this gives
black some additional ideas um this is
one of them I'm not sure if it is good
but it's something that I recently well
when I was thinking about openings some
others idea popped up into my head and
yeah maybe it's interesting the ideas to
go 94 soda castles I'm going to open up
that diagonal and this shouldn't be too
bad I think it looks pretty ok this for
example should be very good compensation
the open files the bishops are very
strong this is an amazing piece
okay here yeah actually doubt that this
is good to see for move because he's now
sitting there with those weaknesses and
this is a very strong piece maybe you
should go nite c4 to make me take on c1
immediately now I'm not taking anymore
oh I could have one here Wow Knight
takes d5 that's a cool move great I mean
check check check very nice or this one
yeah it's the same same showering check
those bishops here very cool again I
didn't see that move one reason for not
seeing it I mean besides that it's not
easy is that I was seeing that with the
normal move like this I had a good
position so I wasn't really am hard
pressed to find something this is very
good he has a very difficult time to
prevent material loss now the engine is
already giving black a great advantage
p.m. see 394 immediately is strong yeah
I probably could have put a one more
efficiently but as long as the the
computer is like on minus 4 i'm happy
try to really keep it simple
think of it so quite quite well yeah
Banco is an interesting opening I have a
project to to compile a bank or
repertoire and release it online I've
not yet started so we'll see about that
okay well thanks for watching